FEMALE SPEAKER: Welcome to
Photographers at Google.
And we are so pleased to
introduce Chris Orwig with us
today.
Chis is a fantastic educator,
speaker, and photographer.
He teaches at Brooks
Institute in Santa Barbara,
and he also has
videos on lynda.com.
You're going to be in
for big treat today.
His topic today is how
getting better at photography
can fuel innovation and growth.
And it is my extreme pleasure
to introduce you to Chris Orwig.
CHRIS ORWIG: All right.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS ORWIG: Thank you.
Super excited to be here.
This is a huge honor.
So for me, I am a
photographer and a teacher.
And over the last
decade or so, I've
had a chance to interact with a
lot of people who were pursuing
or were in pursuit of getting
better at photography.
And what I've discovered
is that that pursuit,
it somehow ignited
a creative spark.
And that that creative
spark is contagious,
and that it leads to creativity
in other areas of their lives.
It makes people more innovative.
It helps to enrich their life.
So what I want to
focus in on today
is this whole idea
of how igniting
that photographic
spark could help
us to be more creative, more
innovative, and more alive.
Sound good?
The way that I want
to try to do that is
to share with you some
photographs, some stories,
and some ideas, which I
hope will change the way
that you approach
photography, because I
think our approach
is really key.
And also, hopefully help
you make better photographs.
And so here I'll just show a
few of my pictures to start off.
And I like to capture pictures
of life as it unfolds.
And so I photograph a lot of
different types of things,
whether it's my daughter
here, or a friend up
in the mountains, or
someone down in the ocean.
And ultimately, for
me, photography really
distills down to this idea that
the French photographer Marc
Riboud once said, he said that
"Photography is savoring life
at 1/100th of a second."
Savoring life intensely.
And I love that idea.
And what I've discovered
is that when I pick up
a camera, whatever kind of
camera it is, and I hold it up
and I look through
it, all of a sudden I
see the world differently, or if
I have a camera on my shoulder
or in my pocket.
And we've all kind
of experienced
this in different ways.
For example, I'll go
back to high school.
My brother and I bought a jeep.
Once I started
driving that jeep,
all of a sudden
what did I notice.
Of course, we know
this one, right.
Other jeeps.
Like oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
All of a sudden I'm waving
to all these other guys who
are driving jeeps, and
they were always there,
it's just that I
couldn't see them.
I was looking, but
I wasn't seeing
because I didn't have
one myself, right?
And so the camera somehow
changes, literally,
what we see, because
it's giving us a chance
to perhaps look a
little bit deeper.
One of my friends
David duChemin,
who's kind of a world
humanitarian photographer I
think said it pretty well.
He said, "The camera first
opened up my eyes, and then
my heart, to a
world of wonders."
And I think that's true.
The camera somehow affects
how we experience life.
And the interesting thing
about photography I think now
is that really we are
all photographers,
to a greater or lesser degree.
I can remember a time
when this wasn't so.
I remember when photography
was only an elective.
It was optional, like
high school photography.
Or maybe it was something you'd
do on a really epic vacation.
But what I've discovered,
what we all know now
is that photography is something
that happens all the time.
I can remember going to my first
concert not too far from here,
and I snuck in a camera.
Did any of you ever do
that back in the day?
And it was a big deal.
And I had this camera, and I
pull it out and take a picture
and then hide it.
And flash forward to, I
saw the same band recently
and there's tens of
thousands of cameras
taking videos and stills now.
And it's part of our life.
And I almost like to think
about photography a little bit
like the Gutenberg press.
So Gutenberg press happened
600 years ago, approximately,
right?
And all of a sudden
it was this boom
of literacy, and curiosity,
and innovation, and knowledge,
and whatnot.
And I think now,
perhaps, it's the camera
in our pocket, whatever
that is, or the one that we
have with us which is creating
a different type of a boom.
It's a different
type of a literacy.
At the same time, something
fascinating is happening.
That's why there are all
these statistics which
are thrown around, like 300
million photographs today will
be posted on Facebook.
And that's an
interesting number.
But I'm more interested in
the number 100 years from now,
right?
What will that be?
And how will we look
back on now and say well,
what is photography
now that it's something
that we all do to
different degrees?
And why I'm saying
all this, and why
I think this is
kind of important
is because I think
the photograph has
a different value.
It's a different way to
communicate and convey.
And I think getting
good at photography
isn't just an option.
Rather, it's get
good at photography.
Pursue getting better
or be left behind.
Because somehow
photography is this force.
It's this part of what we do.
It's no longer kind of fringe.
It's mainstream.
Are you with me on that?
And so what we
have to do is then
say, well, what is
a good photograph?
And so I'll pause
just for a second,
and we did this just
before the talk,
but I want to do it again, to
get you re-thinking about that.
Ask your neighbor, what
is a good photograph?
Go for it.
Let's take 30 seconds
to answer that question.
[AUDIENCE TALKING]
What a good photograph
is is really contingent
upon on who we are.
And sometimes what people
do and your photo teachers
show you a picture
and say is it good?
And then I'll say well, what's
the point, or what's it for?
Do you want to hang
it on your wall, do
you want it to be in a
gallery, is this for education?
What's the intent?
And so the intent really drives
if a photograph is good or not.
Yet we still all sort
of have this idea
that we know the difference
between photographs which
are mediocre, blah,
a little bit empty,
and ones which are
magnificent and compel.
And so in this pursuit
I think it really
is this transition from
mediocre to magnificent.
And I think there
is this idea that we
have to start thinking about
that we are all photographers.
And that this dividing line
between the pro and the amateur
has become blurred.
And maybe isn't even as
relevant as it was before.
Now, this makes a few
people nervous on both sides
of the spectrum.
But on the amateur or
the enthusiast side,
the person who isn't getting
paid for it, sometimes what
will happen, at least
in my experience,
is I'll be shooting
or something,
or they'll be taking pictures
and then I'll walk up
and they're like
oh, you're the pro.
Like you'll take
the real pictures.
But that isn't how it works.
I think the amateur has a
really distinct advantage,
especially even when you're
taking a photograph of a dog,
especially if you're
an ambitious amateur.
And I think the ambitious
amateur has at least
these three things
going for them.
This advantage over
the rest of us.
First one is possibility.
Shunryu Suzuki once said
that "In the beginner's mind,
the possibilities are endless.
In the experts, they're few."
The amateur says well,
why not set my dog up
on this little railing
and ask it to smile?
And that's what the lady did.
It was awesome.
The expert's like no,
there's too many dog pictures
out there.
The amateur says why not?
The next one is passion.
The word amateur, as I'm
sure some of us know,
it comes from the French and the
Latin words which means love.
And so someone who's
an amateur does
something because of that
passion, because they love it,
because they just want to do it.
And that's why most
photographs are made today.
And then the last one is growth.
Edison said, "Discontent is the
first necessity of innovation."
Or invention-- discontent.
And I think the amateur knows
that they can get better.
How many of you have
taken bad pictures,
like horribly bad pictures.
Like oh, my gosh.
There's so much more
potential for growth.
And every pro photographer
I know who's a really, not
every pro, but a lot
of the pros I know,
they're trying to recover
these three things.
They're trying to say, well,
what are the possibilities?
What's possible here?
I want to rekindle that
passion for what I'm doing.
And I also want
to continually say
that photography
is about growth.
It's something that's
different than other things.
You never arrive.
There's no badge, right, that
says you now have arrived
and you take great pictures
and will continue to do so.
Most great
photographers will say
they're only as good as
their last photograph.
And so if you can say,
well this is about growth
and this is about
moving forward,
then those bad pictures
are sometimes OK.
And what we need to do is say
taking good pictures maybe
is the end goal, but getting
there requires bad photographs.
So similar to writing, right?
There are very few writers
that sit down and pen something
and then hand it
off and it's done.
There is process.
Perhaps this process-- well,
it became really clear to me
when my mom took me my brother
and sister on a field trip
to the Hostess factory.
We were little kids.
It was summertime.
And my mom's a crazy artist.
So she took us on
this field trip
and we saw how Hostess
Twinkies were made.
Now, obviously disgusting now.
They don't even exist anymore.
But back then as a kid,
these things were amazing.
And we saw sugar and
flour in a big vat,
stirred around, and go through
a process, and eventually
a Twinkie.
And for us as kids
it was like, wow,
that's the same sugar
and flour that we have.
And then it's the process that
results in something else.
And so photography
I think is something
which is a very similar
type of a thing.
And part of getting good at it
takes really asking yourself
well, who are we?
What's a good photograph to me?
One of my photographic mentor
Rodney Smith here, has really
helped me realize that
who we are, who you are,
determines the
photographs that you make.
And there's this
distinct connection
between who we are and
between our pictures.
So Rodney, he's a really
fascinating person.
He's incredibly
thoughtful, he's profound,
he has this really
interesting sense of humor.
So obviously, these are
couple of his photographs,
those things show
up in his pictures.
And what I've found is it
that the more closely that
our pictures reflect who we are,
the better those photographs
are.
And in a sense, the
photographs that we take
are a bit of a
mirror to who we are.
Elliott Erwitt put it this
way, another photographer.
He said, "Photography has little
to do with the things you see,
and everything to do with
the way that you see them."
That's why when you capture a
photograph, it is, in a sense,
a mirror.
These are a couple
portraits that I made.
And so what is
this mirror saying?
Well, you can kind of tell that
I respect these guys, right?
A world famous
surfer on the left,
and Yvon Chouinard, a great
adventurer, outdoorsman,
founded Patagonia.
You can tell that I admire
their strength of character,
and that I'm really
interested in their eyes
and their presence, right?
Can you see those things?
And if we can make photographs
that reflect this most clearly,
typically they're stronger
than the other ones.
The photographs that are the
worst pictures that I've made,
those are the ones that are a
mirror that's kind of fogged up
after you take a shower.
And you can't really
see through them.
You almost have to wipe it off,
and then even after you wipe it
off, you can't really
see what's happening.
The best pictures are
the ones you're like wow,
I know who took that.
I need to see their name.
I know that's so
and so's photograph.
Or that expresses what's
kind of on the inside, what
I'm trying to
communicate or convey,
and I'm getting that in a frame.
One of the ways that we
do this as photographers
is that we use the frame.
The photographic frame's
kind of an interesting thing.
And for a second, pretend
that you had never seen one.
What you might ask is
why isn't it a circle?
It'd be easy to do.
Like why don't we have
circular photographs?
For some reason, we have
these linear lines, right,
and we have a line
which is usually
a rectangle or a square.
And we use these lines to
somehow eliminate clutter,
or eliminate things
from what we see.
And in order to get
good at photographs,
we have to pay
attention, obviously,
to what we're capturing.
But perhaps more importantly
is what we aren't capturing.
We have to start to think about
how we can frame and reframe.
And I want to hit this
topic just a little bit,
because I think this is where
stuff gets kind of interesting.
This is where who we
are and the way we see
effects the pictures.
And I want to start with
sort of a walk-by photograph.
Have you ever had the moment,
you walk by something,
you're like, oh,
that's pretty cool,
and you take the picture, right?
And this happens to
us, I think, a lot,
especially when you have
your camera with you
because you're sort
of looking for it.
You're peripherally aware
that might look interesting.
And so I was visiting a
friend, Robert Gupta who
plays for the LA Phil at the
Disney Concert Hall in LA.
And it was early in the
morning, the sun was rising.
It's like oh, this is beautiful.
It's interesting.
And this is just the image kind
of straight out of the camera.
But what, perhaps, is
more interesting is
the picture I took
right beforehand.
And this one reveals, I
think, how the camera sees.
It's not good at all, right?
It's clutter, there's
the road and everything.
And what happened I think when
I took the picture is I held it
up, and all of a sudden
when I held up the camera,
it blocked out the
city buildings,
and it blocked out the
trash that was over there.
And I'm like yes, and then I
just zeroed in on the subject.
Yet what we have to
do in photography
is zero in on the subject and
then travel around the frame
and say well,
what's on the edge?
And the art of
learning how to reframe
helps us to create images which
are more clear, which convey,
which somehow draw people in,
which changed from something
which is mediocre or to
maybe even magnificent.
And I don't think this
picture is quite there,
but I think it illustrates
an interesting point.
Let's take another scenario.
This is not a
walk-by photograph,
but one which I'm
trying to set up.
Sometimes you go out and you
find pictures on accidents.
Other times you try to
sort of make pictures.
This is one I'm trying to make.
This is Jack O'Neill in
his home in Santa Cruz,
looking out over the
ocean at some surfers.
And this is the guy
who's often attributed
to having invented the wetsuit.
And I love the sport of
surfing and I love the ocean.
So I love the fact
that we have wetsuits.
I'm grateful to this guy.
So I want to create a
portrait which is timeless,
and which really communicates
and conveys about who he is.
And so this was the frame,
the one that I liked.
But again, I'll show you the
one before in just a second.
Yet before I do I have to
share a quick side story.
You know, when I met him
and I was talking with him,
I noticed that his eye patch was
made out of wetsuit material.
And so, like a smart person,
or smart person that I am,
I said, oh Jack,
I noticed your eye
patch is made of
wetsuit material.
Why is that?
He said, "Well, how else would
I keep my eye socket warm
when I go surfing?"
I was like, right.
OK.
Duh.
But here was the first picture.
Isn't very good
again, and here's why.
It isn't very good because he's
a little bit disengaged, right?
He's not quite looking at me.
He's sort of looking a little
bit just over my shoulder.
Have you ever had that
experience where you're
talking with someone and they're
not quite talking to you.
And you're just not--
you're not there, right?
And then the light
isn't-- the light's fine,
but it's not hitting him good.
His shoulder's a little
bit too far in, right?
He needs to open up.
And then all of a sudden
you're like well, those
are his pots and pans,
and that's his kitchen.
And the portrait I want to
make isn't Jack in is home.
The portrait I want to make is
sort of Jack O'Neill, the man,
the myth, the legend.
This person who looks
like a pirate, who
invented the wetsuit, whose
house hangs out over the ocean.
And in this case, the reframing,
all it took was two feet.
Two feet to the right.
And we're just saying hey, well
Jack, why don't you sit here
and then I'll take that frame.
A very simple reframe.
And that's how good
photographs happen.
But in order for that to happen,
we have to have that mindset.
Maybe it's the rough
draft and the final draft,
but whatever it is,
but it's reframing.
It's the first photo of the
building, the walk-by photo,
and then the second one which
says I'm a photographer.
And you can't say well, I'm
only an amateur photographer
because then the second
frame won't happen, right?
And so we have to get into that.
My friend who's a
travel photographer,
he shoots for
National Geographic,
all these amazing publications.
What he says is when
you're traveling,
the first day, if
you have two days,
the first day you take
the postcard shots.
So if you're in San Francisco
you get the Golden Gate Bridge,
and you get the
Transameri-- whatever it is.
The next day you do the
work of a photographer.
He says if you have 10
minutes with the subject,
the first five minutes you do
the postcard, the obvious shot.
Then the second five minutes you
do the work of a photographer.
And that's all
about that reframe.
You with me on that?
Reframe.
Mediocre to magnificent.
And this, I thought this would
be a fun photo because one
of the early tag lines for
O'Neill wetsuits was it's
always summer on the inside.
And that's a perfect reframe.
I mean those guys were
so cold it's miserable.
And any of you who have been
in the ocean without a wetsuit,
you can't even use your hands.
I remember getting
out of the water
and you would hold
your car keys like this
because you couldn't
open your car door
and you're just so cold.
And he invented this thing
which was about warmth,
and he came up with
this great reframe.
And reframe is
something, I think,
the artists, athletes,
and inventors do.
And somehow it's
that reframe, which
not only affects what we see,
but kind of affects who we are.
So I know this from experience.
So for me, one of the reasons
why I'm a photographer
is I was hit by a car and I
was in a lot of chronic pain.
And I've kind of told
this story other places,
so I'll just make it short.
But I had all of this pain,
and my dad gave me this camera,
and I held it up to my
eye, and all of a sudden I
could reframe.
All of a sudden I found beauty,
and hope, and wonder, even
in despair.
And the camera somehow gave
me this little bit of a gift.
Or maybe going back to, let's
say, the Gutenberg press,
which I mentioned earlier.
The Gutenberg press was invented
in Germany, in wine country.
And so Gutenberg, he
took a wine press,
and rather than pressing grapes,
which he had done many times,
he changed it to press letters.
He went from grapes to letters.
He reframed.
He took something that
was already there.
Printable type was invented in
China like the way before that,
but somehow he just took
this thing and made it new.
And so what we have to do, if
we want to be really creative,
is do that.
And I think photography,
in a sense, is an act.
It's a statement.
And if we have a camera,
again, pocket or whatever,
every time we hold
it up to our eye,
we're saying am I just going to
take what the world gives me?
I'm walking by-- here it
is, the world gave me that.
Boom.
Or am I going to exercise my own
creative power and potential?
Am I going to do more?
And the more that
reframe with the camera,
I think the more we can
reframe in other ways.
For example, I remember when
I was early in my career
and I was working
in an ad agency,
and there was this one person
who would get mad a lot.
Like when it was time for
critique of a project,
he would rant and rave and
arm slam, the whole thing.
And once that happened to me
where he was doing his thing
and he said, I'm
so mad about this.
And I sa well, what
are you mad about that?
And he's like this and that.
I said, great.
And then we moved on and we
developed a relationship.
So rather than cowering,
I said I'm just
going to try to reframe.
I'm going to try to bend
this a different way,
or maybe its spin,
or whatever it is.
And the more we can do those
things, perhaps the more
innovation, maybe
even the more life,
and in photography at least,
the better photographs.
Aristotle said the
aim of art isn't
to display the outward
appearance of things,
but their inward significance.
The aim of art isn't
the outward appearance,
but their inward significance.
And I think in photography
we get hung up on the visual,
right, because
that's the end goal.
Like yeah, look at
that, it's amazing.
But really it's about that inner
truth, or that inner meaning.
Are you with me on that?
Why some photographs
are good to us
is because they have some
sort of significance.
Not just because it's like
that's a pretty picture.
That's my favorite.
That doesn't really
happen, right?
But yeah, that's a pretty
picture, and it's my daughter,
and it's when she was two.
And I remember that moment.
I remember that moment
from that photograph
because she looked up at me, and
she looked up at me and said,
dad-- and this is
my daughter Annie.
She said, dad,
you have rainbows!
And I said why are you
talking-- She's like, no,
you have rainbows!
And she was talking about
the wrinkles on my forehead.
And she counted them,
and she would kiss them.
And this is my favorite feature
of my body, my rainbows.
They're just going to
get better with time.
And my other two daughters, now
they talk about my rainbows.
And again, it was that
inner significance,
that moment perhaps.
And what we do as photographers,
we tell stories with light.
The word photography,
as we know,
comes from that Greek
word photos and graphos.
It's light and writing,
writing with light.
In the visual arts,
photography is
all about how do we convey,
communicate with light.
But the trick, of course, is
we can't go to an art store
and buy ink or pencils
like other artists,
visual artists can do.
We can't go by lights, right?
We have to sort of pursue
it and discover it.
And it's this bit of
this chase almost.
I like to think of the pursuit
of light similar to what
my tribe or my friends do
when they pursue waves.
Does anyone know
a surfer in here?
They're crazy people, right?
And what they do is they
go to the far corners
of the world looking for waves.
And they find waves
because of their search
in all of these unlikely places.
And they only find them
because they're on the hunt.
And the same thing's
true with photography.
Like with these two
pictures, both of them
sort of happened by accident.
With the one on the right,
this happened about a week ago.
I was driving down a dirt
road and the sun was rising,
and I know dirt
and sun and light,
and I was like there's got--
And I was oh, stop the car.
Jump out.
Capture the frame.
The dust settled and
the moment was gone.
But it was that
pursuit, that awareness,
that light is here or around.
And it's there, maybe
just around the corner.
We can discover it.
And if you believe in light,
perhaps you might even find it.
And with this other
one, I was shooting
the opposite direction, but
the light was too harsh,
and then all of a
sudden it was oh.
And it was, again, it
was that turnaround.
And that whole
pursuit of lightness
may sound a little bit of
a stretch for some people,
but I think that that
search brings new life.
If you do a Google
search for light,
and read some of the entries,
or the Wikipedia entry,
or whatever it is, it will say
that almost every thing that's
alive on planet Earth can
trace its life back to light.
Light is like the
great source of life.
You with me on that?
I mean light gives life.
And if that's what
you're looking
for, somehow that
effects you, right?
Because, again, you start
to see it and notice it,
and it changes, I think,
how you appreciate the world
and what you see.
This, though, of course, isn't
just a Pollyanna pursuit.
This isn't about go
photograph sunsets
or sunrises and puppy dogs.
I think the pursuit of
light is something more.
Dylan Thomas, "Do not go
gentle into that good night,
but rage, rage, against
the dying of the light."
This is something
that all artists know.
Light, and the passage of time.
We all know that one day
the lights of our life
will be gone.
The reason why I decided
to pursue photography,
I began, perhaps, because
I was hit by a car.
But then I pursued it because
I was in graduate school.
I wasn't studying
photography, but I
was required to
volunteer in a hospital.
And I was assigned
to the floor where
people were being treated
for, wrestling with, and dying
from cancer.
And my job was to
sit and just listen.
To be a neutral party who would
just spend time with them.
And what I discovered
is that by spending time
with people who are dying,
you can't help but learn
about life.
In this pursuit of light, I
think is somehow tied to life
itself.
The camera, in my experience,
is an amazing teacher.
That's one of the reasons why
I think we like photography.
It helps us to
remember things, right?
You see something
interesting, you're
like oh, I'll remember that.
It's also helped us to
really savor moments.
Like so I was
talking with someone
earlier who photographs food.
When you photograph
food you're like oh,
I just want to remember
and kind of savor this
before I gobble it up.
And it also teaches us
something about time.
And there's a
proverb in the Bible
which says teach us
to number our days
so that we can be wise.
And I think having
this prospectus
makes us realize
life is precious.
And sometimes when you
look back at photographs,
you learn this truth.
Somehow it can sort of
wrinkle the fabric of time.
And this is a small picture,
but a very important one.
This is a photograph
of my dad, one
of the most important
people in my life.
The reason I am who I
am in a lot of ways.
And there he is with
my oldest daughter.
It's a few years old.
And when you capture a
photograph like this,
what you're doing is you're
savoring that moment.
Ah, this is great, my
dad and my daughter.
But then when you look
at it, what happens
is I realize that's me.
That's me who he used
to hold, and that's
me who now holds her.
And then it goes backwards,
but it also goes forwards.
And I think one day, even
now as I look at this,
I realize that I'm going
to look at this photograph
in the future when
my dad's gone.
And I'm going to look at this
with just immense sadness.
And that's part of the
beauty of this moment.
And the thing that's
interesting about this
is photographically
speaking, rule of thirds
and all these different rules,
it isn't even that good,
but it's good to me.
And sometimes the
best photographs
are the ones which have
that meaning, which
somehow reflect who we are.
And maybe even shape
the way that we
experience and understand time.
Part of photography,
obviously, is story, right?
And sometimes the way
that we tell stories
are these little teeny slices
of life stories from daily life.
And again, I'm a dad
with three daughters.
I love my girls, so I have
to show a few photos of them.
But in these photos, we have
Annie, my oldest daughter,
who was little in
that previous picture.
And there she is with
curlers in her hair.
The first time she ever
had curlers in her hair,
and she's sitting
in her grandmother's
rocking chair with her youngest
sister, and she's tickling her.
And there's that great laugh.
And then on the left we
have Elsie, the third kid
in our family, the one who
has to go and feed herself.
When everyone else
eating breakfast,
she's not getting food, she
just goes in and goes for it.
And it captures these
small little stories.
And so the stories that
we tell and try to convey
are really, really important.
And sometimes they're
slice of life stories.
Those are important, but those
aren't professional pictures.
Who cares?
That's where that amateur
advantage comes in.
You with me on that?
Sometimes those
are more important
than the big pictures.
And there are other
stories to tell as well.
Sometimes, perhaps,
they're more subtle.
Sometimes there's
maybe a narrative arc.
This photograph,
my friend Martin,
best friend in
the world, here he
is at Witch's Rock in
Costa Rica, where he lives.
He doesn't live at Witch's Rock,
but he lives in Costa Rica.
We're surfing at this
really famous surf spot.
Have any of you ever
seen surf photographs?
Like kind of picture
one in your head.
A guy doing a maneuver,
guy in a wave, that's it.
End of story.
I've seen it a million times.
I didn't want that picture.
And Witch's Rock, if
I were to show you
all of Witch's Rock, which
is hidden by the wave,
you'd be like ah, Witch's Rock.
Nice one, Chris.
But I hid it.
I got low.
So I'm swimming in the water.
And it's a moment before
he catches the wave, right?
It's that little narrative arc.
And I love what
E.M. Forster says
about narrative versus plot.
He says this.
Says that "Plot
is the queen died,
the King died, end of story.
Narrative, the queen died.
The King died of heart break."
Two little words, but all
of a sudden there's a story.
And all of a sudden, the story
adds some sort of meaning.
And it's that
connective thread which
somehow makes the
photograph a bit stronger.
So to keep you guys
with me because I've
been talking a lot, I'm
going to take another 30
seconds, conversation with
our neighbor, which is--
and if you're
watching this online,
you could maybe pause and
ask yourself this question.
And the question is this.
Neighbor, what is something
which has resonated with you?
Something that has
been said that you're
going to sort of put in your
pocket and walk away with?
It could be as simple as
reframe, that's my thing.
Or it could be something else.
So we have 30 seconds.
Ask your neighbor,
neighbor, what
is the one thing so
far that resonates?
Go for it.
[AUDIENCE TALKING]
Are you guys enjoying
things so far?
Gain some interesting
insight to photography?
Hopefully, a little
bit different.
So I give you
Jackie Robinson who
said "Life isn't a
spectator sport."
and I think we could trade the
word life with photography.
Photography isn't
a spectator sport.
But unfortunately, for
so many of us it is.
We sort of look at
pictures from a distance.
Or someone talks about
photography, maybe myself,
and you're like, wow,
that's a great picture,
but it doesn't do
anything for you.
And what you have to say is
well, what do I take away,
and then how does that affect
the photographs that I make?
And each time you
see photographs,
I think it's helpful
to ask that question,
why is this resonating?
And why is this resonating
with me right now?
What makes this photograph good?
The more we can start to
shape and form and answer
that question, the
more we can, then,
create those photographs which
actually mirror who we are,
versus just say something
plain, mediocre and blah.
All right.
Ben Harper, the musician.
"Sometimes the story
or the narrative arc
is best when it's subtle."
Moments before I took
this picture of him,
there was someone else
capturing a photograph of him.
And she was trying
to get Ben to smile.
And Ben's kind of the uber
cool rock star musician guy.
And she was saying, Ben,
smile, smile, smile.
And finally she said,
Ben, say cheese.
And he snapped back.
And he said, lady, I
smile with my eyes.
She was kind of frustrated
and then walked away.
And then in my
picture I think he is.
He isn't showing his teeth, but
I think there's a smile there.
And sometimes in photography,
the best photographs
are those ones which
sort of just draw you in.
There's a subtlety to it
which keeps pulling you in.
There are other pictures which
are big and bold, you walk by,
you can't help but notice them.
But it's almost like it's
too loud or too much.
It's stewed with too
much seasoning or salt,
or it's music which is
just that much too loud.
Are you with me on that?
But the art which really
resonates and really stirs
and connects is the one
sometimes where that narrative
arc is just those two little
words, died of heart break,
or whatever it is, or a
smile, perhaps, with the eyes.
And the beauty of these kind
of things is in photography,
say like for me, I love
photographing people.
All of a sudden Ben Harper
taught me an important lesson.
Happiness and smile isn't
just right here, right?
It can be the face.
You can see someone
smiling with their posture.
Just the way they're standing.
You can see a tree
that's smiling,
or a tree that's really just
weathered, and sad, and worn.
And the expression
isn't always typical.
It isn't always obvious.
Sir William Empson wrote
about literature this way.
I like to compare literature
and writing to starter fuel.
He said, "Great literature
makes us think and feel
conflicting things
at the same time."
And sometimes what that means
is we can see a photograph
and we can have these
different feelings all at once.
This is a picture of
another world famous surfer,
world champion surfer.
And this photograph
was captured the year
that he lost his
18-year-old son.
And I think in this
photograph, now
that you know that, you
can kind of see that.
You can see that
there's strength,
there's a life well lived,
there's strong character,
but there's a bit of sadness.
And sometimes when it comes to
stories, especially when we're
new to writing stories, we
think it has to be one thing.
It's just like a strong
story, or it's just a--
But no, the story's, and
the music, and the art
that we like the most, it
has this duality to it.
This subtlety to it.
And so, what we have
to do is as we think
about creating our
own photographs,
or creating better
photographs, because that's
why we're all here, right, is
say well, how do we do that?
One way I think
is by simplifying.
And this isn't just simplifying
reframing, like we said.
This is simplifying
more like the poet.
The poet will take what the
novelist does in 20,000 words
and say it in 20.
And after a poem,
what I found is we
not only have more information,
but we have more experience,
and somehow they
reduce and simplify.
But not just that.
It's like a reduction,
a simplification,
and then they also deepen.
If you don't like
poetry, take song lyrics.
Usually a song's only
three minutes long.
If a song's 20 minutes
long, it's just too much.
It's like they're
going on and on and on.
But when you reduce and
simplify it to something,
somehow you can say more.
And so some of the pictures
that are interesting,
or as you start to
compose those pictures,
is to ask yourself well,
how can I work like a poet?
And what poets do is
something which is intriguing.
W.B. Yeats gives us some
insight into the life
of a poet with these lines.
"A line will take us hours.
Yet if it doesn't seem
a moment's thought,
our stitching and
unstitching has been naught."
Ever seen a fake photograph--
posed, overproduced?
Have you ever listened to
music that's overproduced?
It's just too perf--
and you're like--
In food photography,
which I mentioned before,
that type of photography taught
me really important lesson.
What someone does
in food photography,
they styled a dish
so it looks amazing.
It looks perfect.
And then they had crumbs.
They add a few flaws,
because that flaw,
it somehow draws it in.
And I think that's what,
somehow, good poets do.
They make it real.
They make it somehow authentic
and believable so that we're
drawn into it, and
it slows us down so
that we can absorb that.
Silence obviously
does this, as well.
Photographers or
cameras can be noisy.
Not all cameras, and I
think that's the beauty
of a lot of our pocket cameras
is there's no click, right?
And they're quiet.
And so there's the camera,
but then there's also us.
Silence is an incredibly
powerful mode of communication.
This is my daughter,
Sophie, and this is just
captured with a camera phone.
Christmas morning at
her grandparent's house.
And I just love
this simple moment.
And it couldn't have been
captured had I said something.
She didn't know the
frame was being made.
If I had said, wait, Sophie,
Sophie, look towards me
and smile, would you
like the photograph?
My mom might like
it, but would you?
No, right?
But this one it's
kind of interesting.
Or my other daughter
Annie after a day
of skiing up in
Mammoth Mountain.
And again, a photograph
captured without words.
So often in photography,
let's say people
photography, where you
get that caricature
that you're supposed
to say something.
Work it, work it,
great, great, great.
But sometimes what
we can do is just
be quiet and let the
picture take place.
And by doing that
often, it can let
the photograph have perhaps
a bit of a voice of its own.
William Penn writes,
"True silence
is the rest of the
mind, and it is
to the spirit what
sleep is to the body,
nourishment and refreshment."
The camera I think is
an amazing teacher.
And one of things
that it's taught me
is that there is a
time to be quiet.
It's not always about
me saying something.
Sometimes it's about slowing
down, simplifying, reframing,
and just letting things be.
In our current era, we have
access to amazing cameras
which capture near
perfect pictures.
And as a result, we
kind of have this idea
that good photographs are
photographs which somehow
have everything
sort of just right.
But what I have found
is that sometimes it's
a flaw that makes the frame.
These are a few portraits.
One of the characters we've
seen before, Jack O'Neil there,
captured with old expired film.
And it's almost like
the mistake there
allows us to be drawn in to
what the narrative arc is.
Here's a photograph of
the singer and songwriter
Seal at his home, sitting
there at his desk.
And while we were sitting there
he said something interesting.
He said when I shoot
with film cameras-- Well,
he started off saying, when
I shoot with digital cameras
and open up those files,
I look for the problem.
I look for the mistake.
I find the flaw, and then
I correct it with software.
He said when I shoot
with film, I embrace it.
And this isn't about
film versus digital,
this is about photography.
And this is about as
we capture images,
are we willing to embrace
those little flaws,
those crumbs, maybe
even add a few crumbs.
Or are we in this pursuit
for perfect pictures?
And this could mean
something like this,
a portrait of someone-- there's
some guys in the background.
Should we shoo them
out of the picture?
Why not leave them there.
It adds some ambiance
or some depth.
And sometimes it
means other things.
Like my daughter Annie,
she was leaving for school
and it was crazy hair day.
And so I said, Annie, let me
capture a picture real quick
before you go.
And I took that one.
Then I said, hey, let
me capture one more.
And this is the face of a
photographer's daughter, right?
And I almost like that one more.
And it's the flaw
that she intentionally
made the crazy hair, and that
moment, and those bright eyes,
and that stage in life.
So we're getting near the end.
Tips and review.
How to make better
photographs, at least
for our conversation here.
The first thing I want you
to really walk away with
is this idea of
finding the photograph.
And I'm going to walk
through two pictures.
This is of my daughter Sophie
last weekend at the beach.
And I want to kind of review
or walk through a few ideas.
The first one is
when you see a scene,
or when you go out to capture
a scene, at least in my mind,
you want your heart
to be beating fast.
You want to say this is it.
I'm so interested
in photographing
this gorilla or this
hawk, or this mountaintop,
or this person, whatever it is.
And this is savoring
what that item is.
And I want to do that right now.
And so you capture the frame.
And you kind of get
caught up, maybe even
in the passion of it.
Because photography, for the
photographs that are best,
they're not taken from a
distance, cold and isolated.
They're you're in there
and you capture the image.
And then you have to
say, OK, you know what?
This first frame may
not be the best frame.
I'm going to embrace
the amateur advantage.
And for myself,
personally, I always do.
In other words, I
capture this picture
and it actually isn't great.
It's not the right
picture for me.
And the reason it's
not the right picture,
there's some stuff
in the foreground,
she's turned a
little bit too much,
she's not quite
right in the middle.
It's low tide.
Low tide in the fall in
Santa Barbara where I live
is the best time of year.
I just love it.
And you can either
say, you know what?
I'm no good.
You can say, I'm an amateur,
and what else is possible?
And why do I want to
make this picture?
And how can I grow?
And then so you say, well,
maybe what I can do is reframe.
Maybe I can find a
picture within a picture.
Or maybe I can do
what Gutenberg did.
I can take the wine press and
convert it for something else.
And that's the frame.
That's what my I saw.
I just wasn't
quite close enough.
I need to move somehow
physically to get there.
And then what I can do
is move and get closer,
and I got closer to her and
had her turn just a little bit.
And I like this photograph much
more because I'm connected.
I can actually see her, right?
You're getting a
little bit up close.
But then at that moment, I
think it's really important
to slow down and be quiet, and
almost listen to the photograph
and say, well, yeah,
this is a good picture.
This is a rough draft
that's been revised.
But maybe, is there more?
And I'll talk a little bit more
about this idea of listening,
but one of the things
that I want to do
is I know that when
the waves come through,
and you guys all know this,
it just cleans out the sand,
right?
Ever seen sand which
is just perfect?
And so I can sort of listen
or slow down or stop or say
what would the poet do?
And then it's this frame.
And it's just that
next little moment.
And when you get
to those moments,
there also always
has to be this point
where you resist perfection.
In photography,
you'll hear people
say your horizon
needs to be level.
It isn't perfectly level.
Or maybe your hair isn't styled
just right, or whatever it is.
You have to say you know what?
This is the moment.
I'm going to embrace that frame.
You have to sort of let
go of critique in a sense
and let it be what it is.
And so here is the process.
Find the photograph.
So, again, if you walk
away with one thing,
ask yourself in this
process, how can
I do this the next time I hold
up my camera, whatever it is.
The second thing that
I would suggest to you
is to spend some time
to study and learn.
We are all photographers to
a greater or lesser degree.
Yet what's so interesting
is very few of us
actually study the craft.
Out of those 300
million photographs
which are posted on
Facebook or wherever today,
very few of those are
thoughtful photographs,
or ones which are trying to
accomplish or say something.
There isn't much maybe study
or practice behind them.
And so what I
recommend you do is
begin by trying to absorb
greatness through a book.
An old-fashioned paper book.
I have a friend who's a
great cinematographer,
and what he'll do is
he'll sit down with a book
rather than watch TV.
And he'll give it an
episode's length amount
of time, half an hour.
And he'll just absorb
the photographs.
And if you can be
around good photographs,
all of a sudden you can discover
little insights and nuances,
which you may want to
integrate into what you do.
The other thing
that I recommend is
to try to learn
from the legends.
I'll show you two photographs
captured by John Sexton,
an amazing photographer-- used
with permission, of course.
And this is one picture
and then another.
One of the things that I have
learned from John is this.
He once said, and I've seen
he's written in other places,
that he listens to the trees.
And at first I kind
of wrote that off,
like what is this some
kind of new age speak?
And then I realized no,
this is incredibly profound.
Have you ever seen
two people talking
to each other and you can't
hear what they're saying?
And one person is
completely disinterested,
and you can tell
how they listen--
posture's a little bit
down, sort of looking away.
Or the opposite, too.
Lovers are good friends, and
you can see someone listening.
And if they have
really good news,
you can see the person just
respond, and they're so
with them and present.
Or maybe if it's sad news
and they're listening,
you can see them just absorb--
that there's thoughtfulness--
absorb whatever has been said.
And I think that listening
is about a posture,
being open to what's before us.
And great photographs happen
from moments like this.
So when you study these
legends, all of a sudden you
discover these little truths.
And while I don't
photograph trees,
I do photograph other
things, and listening
has become a part of my craft.
You with me?
Study.
Study the legends.
Last one.
Photograph what matters most.
If you can make photographs
that are more meaningful to you,
there's a chance they'll be
more meaningful to someone else.
Like with this picture
here, it was such a journey
to try to get to the
top of the mountain.
By the time I was at
the top, I was curled up
in a ball in my tent
because I was so tired.
And finally I just crawled
out and I captured this frame.
But it meant something to me.
The view.
I sort of earned the view.
And it was painful to get there.
And if you can create
a photograph that
has meaning to
you, it might just
mean something to someone else.
This is one of my favorite
spots to go surfing.
This is one of my best
friends and his son.
And if you make your
own photographs, ones
that have meaning to you, rather
than someone else's, they'll
go farther.
They'll become better.
For a long time I've tried
to photograph oak trees.
And I tried, and I
tried, and I tried,
and I couldn't get any
good pictures of them.
And I realized because
what I was doing
was impersonating other
photographs of oak trees
that I had seen.
And it wasn't until
this picture that I
feel like I finally got closer.
I was no longer impersonating.
I was trying to
capture one of my own.
Because this was my tree, in
my parents' backyard where
I grew up.
Whereas I grew up, I climbed
a little bit higher and higher
and higher, and there are
rope swings and forts.
This is my tree.
And if you can make photographs
that are meaningful to you,
that you sort of own,
they'll become better.
They'll be that clear reflection
of the mirror of who you are.
This is my wife and
our daughter Annika,
after a little dance recital.
And with all of
this, I think what
it means is to get
started where you are.
The trick with
photography is like well,
if only I was in Italy, then
I could get some great travel
photos.
Or if only I was working
with this celebrity,
then I would create
a great portrait.
But photography, and
the best photography
starts where you are
and emanates out.
You bring that with
you wherever you go.
Photograph what matters most.
One link.
My website /learn.
There's some
resources there if you
want to dig into other topics in
regards to specifics, like how
do you do certain things, and
composition, and lighting,
and software, which
we didn't cover.
Really, this was
more about the heart,
and about the pursuit of
getting better at photography.
And then, of course last,
but not least, thank you.
It was a real honor.
[APPLAUSE]